et c'est dans ce contexte qu'un
quatrième round de discussions sera de
nouveau engagé aujourd'hui par
visioconférence des échanges qualifiés
ces dernières heures de plutôt bon par
le président ukrainien les re sont
commencés dit il à comprendre qu'ils ne
parviendront à rien par la guerre
écouter le
shakedown les représentants des
délégations de nos pays par le temps
visioconférence tous les jours notre
délégation un objectif clair faire en
sorte d'organiser une réunion entre les
présidents une réunion qui est j'en suis
sûr attendu par nous peuple bien sûr
c'est difficile à mettre en place c'est
beaucoup demander mais c'est nécessaire
à l'homme fort rodd qui est bien qu'il
va recevoir aujourd'hui le soutien
appuyé de ses voisins puisque on l'a
appris ce matin les premiers ministres
polonais tchèques et slovènes vont se
rendre aujourd'hui à kiev en qualité de
représentant du conseil européen
l'objectif rencontrer le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky et son
premier ministre